hi it's michelle from live muffin beauty
science here chemistry phd skin care
nerd and sunscreen nerd
being the sunscreen no person i get a
lot of questions about unusual sunscreen
products and whether or not their claims
work out
last time i talked about the color
science powder sunscreen and the
skinny's pea-sized amount claim
i'll link that in the description this
time i'm back with two more products
that lots and lots of people have asked
me about
evie has a range of high-tech foam
sunscreens that are meant to last for
really long on your skin so six to eight
hour claims
in water with towel rubbing dermablend
have the flawless creative pigment drops
that you're meant to be able to mix into
sunscreens without compromising the spf
protection
like i mentioned last time i tried to
talk to the company to
work out what their reasoning is behind
the claim why exactly are they making
the claim what evidence they have
and then i try to match that with what
we know about sunscreen
i try to keep an open mind about
innovations even if they sound pretty
unusual
because as we all know sunscreen is not
that great a lot of the time there are
lots of issues and that's why a lot of
people don't apply enough or they don't
apply it properly or they might not even
wear sunscreen at all
and there are also a lot of innovations
that just don't show up in the
peer-reviewed literature
so a lot of the time there's just no
incentive for a company to
conduct the research and get it to a
point where we'll be accepted in the
peer-reviewed literature
sometimes it's just too new to be there
sometimes
they just want to protect their
intellectual property and sometimes
there are complicated legal reasons
why we don't have them there so i think
it's really important to
talk to the company and try to
understand where they're coming from
again a disclaimer these are my opinions
i could be wrong
if you disagree then let me know in the
comments
please don't sue me please if you like
nerding out about the science behind
skincare products click the like the
subscribe and the notification bell so
you don't miss any videos
let's start with evie evie are a swedish
sunscreen brand and they have a range of
these
moose sunscreen products they're really
popular in sweden and
in europe and their most impressive
claim is that their sunscreen lasts
through a lot
so it lasts through six to eight hours
on your skin it lasts through
dipping into water it lasts through
sweat towel rubbing and so on
their claims have actually been on my
radar for a while because
they're really amazing claims they
really solve some issues that we have
with sunscreens and it would be amazing
if they were true
and based on the data i've looked at i
think it could actually be true
i bet some of you never thought i would
actually say that so most sunscreen
products rely
on the sorts of formulation tricks that
barrier creams use as well
so in other words they try to make the
sunscreen stay on
a layer on the top of your skin and they
try to make that layer as continuous and
even and
as long lasting as possible some of
these creams also sink a little bit into
the top layers of skin
but the problem with the product that's
mostly on the top layer is that it's on
the outside
and so it shifts around it gets rubbed
off and
over time that protection decreases and
that's why you're meant to reapply your
sunscreen every two hours
so to try to deal with these issues some
sunscreens use
different technologies to get those
sunscreen ingredients a little bit
deeper into the skin into the stratum
corneum the top dead layers
you might have heard of liposomal
sunscreens these have little liposomes
in them they're sort of like little
micelles
and so these package the sunscreen
ingredients until
it goes into your stratum conium and
then it releases them
so you end up with a layer that's in the
top layer of your skin
so it doesn't get rubbed off as much and
it's not deep enough that it'll still be
near the surface it'll still be an
effective
screen evie uses a special patient that
involves a mix
of glycerin dimethicone and fatty acids
like lauric acid and stearic acid
this patient is actually used for other
things as well
so it's used in some treatments for
atopic dermatitis or eczema
and one really interesting thing about
this patient is that it can actually
increase your skin's resistance it
increases the barrier function
so it works as a better barrier and this
is very unusual for a penetration
enhancer because a lot of the time
penetration enhances that get things
deeper into your skin
will actually decrease your barrier
function so it opens it up a bit so that
things can get through
this is slightly different it seems to
deliver it and then seal it in
another bonus because this isn't a
barrier is that it also doesn't seem to
interfere with sweating
and it doesn't make you feel as hot the
biggest bonus with sunscreen of course
is that because
it's a little bit deeper it doesn't get
wiped away or washed away anywhere near
as easily
so there's a mechanism for why heavy
sunscreens might work better than other
sunscreens but
does it actually hold out in practice
evie is sold in sweden
and the eu and they tend to have higher
requirements for claims compared to
other countries they're also a pretty
famous brand in sweden they've won lots
of awards
so it's not really like they'd slip
under the radar of their regulators
so i asked evie if i could see their
tests and they were nice enough to show
me and they said i could share some of
the results here
i don't think they showed me all of
their tests because i think there's some
intellectual property stuff they want to
keep some stuff private
but yeah i'm really impressed by the
tests i've seen so far and i get the
feeling that they've done
a lot more tests on their products than
a standard company would
with the tests i saw they sent their
sunscreens to a third-party testing lab
and this lab used modified versions of
the official iso tests for
spf and for water resistance i talked
about the iso spf test in my video on
pareto
basically they put the sunscreen at two
milligrams per square centimeter on the
backs of volunteers and then they expose
them to uv
and see how much uv it takes for them to
get sunburned so these are the tests
they performed on the longevity claims
firstly the claim that it lasts for
eight hours on skin this was done
on two of their sunscreens they took the
sunscreens put it on the volunteers and
then tested the spf
and then they waited eight hours and
then tested the spf again
and with both of these the spf actually
increased after eight hours
now i'm not sure if the spf actually
increased because the sunscreen
interacted with the skin differently
or if it's just experimental error but i
think either way it's a pretty good
indication that the sps stays
at least around the same they also
performed an 8 hour water resistance
test on their spf 50 moose now the
standard water resistance test
is only 80 minutes so this is 480
minutes
which is six times normal they put the
sunscreen on the volunteers they sat in
a whirlpool for a total of eight hours
so the actual protocol is they go in and
then they come out and they go in and
they come out
and then um in total though in the
whirlpool they were there for eight
hours
which is a lot then after the eight
hours of dipping probably more like 12
14 hours in total
they let the sunscreen area air dry and
then they tested the spf again
the spf went from 53 down to 35.2
which is not a massive drop it's really
impressive
for eight hours they also did towel
abrasion tests on two of their
sunscreens so they applied the sunscreen
they waited 20 minutes
and then they took a towel and applied
moderate pressure and stroked over it
several times
then they tested the spf again and for
both of the sunscreens the sps stayed
around the same
they also tested sweat resistance so
volunteers had to sit inside a sauna
at 37ish degrees for at least an hour of
sweating so they started the timer
when the volunteer started sweating
profusely so there were like drips going
over the sunscreen
and then after that they tested the spf
and for both of the sunscreens tested
the spf went down a little bit about 10
percent
they also did the standard 80 minutes of
water resistance with different types of
water so they did chlorinated water and
they did salt water
and in both of these circumstances the
spf went down about 10
i am really impressed they have done
quite a lot of in vivo clinical testing
on actual humans with their actual
sunscreens
this is pretty rare when it comes to
sunscreens because these tests are
really expensive
i am really impressed if you look at my
old video you can see some examples
where people try to use
less expensive tests and just join the
dots rather than actually test it
in real life on real people one issue
with these supplementary extracurricular
tests is that they were only done on two
or three people
unlike the standard spf test which is
generally done on 10 people
so these are going to be less reliable
results than the standard 10 people test
but if you look at the individual
results they're actually quite in close
agreement
so i think it's reasonably reliable i
would obviously
prefer more subjects and maybe tests
from different labs i think evie
are actually working on getting tests
from different labs for their claims
but i also understand that these tests
are really expensive and it can be
really hard to get volunteers
like if you look at the protocols they
are pretty nasty like
i would probably not want to get
sunburned and then
go in and out of a hot tub for 12 14
hours and then get sunburned again that
just sounds like
medieval torture and this is considered
enough by the regulators to substantiate
their claims so
there's not really a big incentive to
pay so much more for tests that
tell you pretty much the same thing so i
think these claims are pretty legit
but i also understand the regulatory
perspective
where the regulators in some countries
just don't want to let a brand claim
that their product lasts for six hours
even though we have these results
these tests were done on a small area of
skin with perfect application but in
real life
people don't apply enough they don't
apply sunscreen in certain areas they
skip bits like between your eyes around
your eyes sometimes the top of an ear
having a second application means you
can fix that mistake
and so instead of having a bare patch
for six hours you would have a bare
patch for two hours
i personally use the heavy sunscreen and
i trust the six hour claim
but i still personally try to reapply
every two hours because i know that my
application a lot of the time isn't that
great
but i appreciate the fact that this
sunscreen is a lot more resistant to
whatever i happen to be doing
and it's like an extra level of backup
in case i
forget to reapply on time the other
product i'm talking about today
is the dermablend flawless creator drops
dermablend is a l'oreal brand and
they're famous for their high coverage
products so they can cover up tattoos
they can cover up
different types of pigmentation flawless
creator drops are pigmented drills that
you can use as a really
lightweight foundation or you can mix
them into other products
and supposedly you can mix them into
your sunscreen without compromising the
protection
it's been mentioned in sponsored content
so i assume it comes from the brand
it was mentioned on their website i
think it's currently not mentioned on
their website but in their product
descriptions on
ulta and on macy's it's still there
usually those product descriptions are
supplied by the brand
it's also on their instagram highlights
reel it's on
some of their posts on their page they
said it in their responses from customer
service
and this would be amazing if it were
true because white cast in sunscreens
is a big problem if you're in the us and
you're sensitive to avobenzone then
you're kind of stuck with mineral
sunscreens and mineral sunscreens have a
white cast
so if you have darker skin and you put
on a standard mineral sunscreen your
face goes white and ghostly looking
and it's not very nice tinted sunscreens
usually only come
in like three colors and if you're not
one of those three colors then you're
going to look a little bit weird if you
apply the right amount
so this way you can mix in one of these
many shades of pigment and get your own
custom tinted sunscreen
but the issue of course is whether or
not it actually works
because mixing anything into a sunscreen
could potentially disrupt its ability to
form a continuous film
and it's that continuous film that will
be protecting you
you don't want random gaps and cracks in
your sun protection there's a study from
july 2020 in the journal of drugs and
dermatology from dermablend
that some people have sent me and they
said that this is the study that some
people are citing
for proof that the spf isn't compromised
and i've looked at this i actually
looked at it for my blue light
video which i will link below and it
actually doesn't have anything to do
with mixing and it doesn't have anything
to do with spf
so no this study does not show that we
can do it this way so i reached out to
dermablend
actually i reached out about seven times
since october
they said they'd send me the data a few
times and then
eventually after a lot of back and forth
mostly
forth from me and a little bit of back
from them i
ended up with this response in my dms we
at dermablend recommend following the
current fda guidelines for sunscreen
application
and directions for use on the sunscreen
you are applying
we continually research to innovate and
improve our products
in order to share emerging learnings
with dermatologists so this is obviously
a very carefully constructed and formal
statement
and i'm not sure what happened between
them promoting it
to be used in this way and this
statement i'm guessing it's one of two
things
they have studies that they believe show
that mixing is fine but they want to
play it safe and not piss off the fda
so they are tapping the sign or they've
realized that they don't have enough
evidence to recommend it after all and
so they're walking it back
either way it seems like the official
stance from dermablend is not to mix the
pigment drops into your sunscreen so
don't mix the pigment drops into your
sunscreen but it seems like they haven't
really put a lot of effort into telling
people about this change in their policy
i think they've deleted some of their
instagram posts because
since october i remember commenting on
some of their posts like i just waited
for them to post about the dermablend
drop so that i could drop in a relevant
comment
asking them politely for their data and
i can't actually find my comments
anymore so i think they must have
deleted some of the posts
but it's still on the descriptions for
flawless creator on the ultra macy's
websites
they have a tutorial in their instagram
story highlight
showing you how to mix it into sunscreen
they have a quote from an interview with
a dermatologist
talking about how great it is to mix
these drops into sunscreen
and they even have an instagram tutorial
with hiram
talking about showing you how to mix it
into your sunscreen i want to make it
clear that i'm not blaming hiram for
anything because like i said a lot of
the content from the brand
has this tip and so i'm pretty sure the
brand told him he could do this
and why would you not trust a brand
that's recommended by so many
dermatologists
so i think dermablend could probably
just put a bit more effort into
communicating this change in their
advice because
what's in my gms is very different from
what you would get
if you just look through the internet so
if i were producing a product like this
this is how i would test the claim i get
a bunch of consumers to mix the pigment
drops into the sunscreens themselves
to see how much they mix and how they
mix it like how thoroughly
then i would replicate the worst case
scenarios in the lab with a bunch of
different sunscreen formulations
and then test them on people and see
what the spf is see if the spf drops
if the sps stays around the same for all
the common sunscreen formulations then i
would be happy with that claim
if it doesn't because there are a lot of
different sunscreen formulas there are
lots of different
technologies used in different
sunscreens so yeah i'd like to see
that done on a range of sunscreens and
have it stay
good so i don't know if that's possible
i'm guessing the dross would have to
have some spf protection in them for
that to work
and yeah there's just so many different
formulations with sunscreens
that i think it would be really
difficult to make sure it didn't
destabilize
any of them i'm not sure if it's
possible but
maybe it is that's it for today remember
these are just my opinions on the claims
from these companies with the
information i have
maybe there's some information i don't
have that would be relevant as well
let me know if you agree or disagree in
the comments also let me know if you
have other spf products with weird
claims that you want me to go through
i hope you liked this video if you did
give it a thumbs up you can subscribe to
my channel
as well check me out on instagram and
check out my blog
and i will see you next time
you